قد اتهم راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
السلطه بممارسه الاستهداف السياسي بوسائل
قضائيه وقال انما يجري في تونس معركه بين
الديمقراطيه والديكتاتوريه التي تريد
مصادره مكاسب الثوره وفق تعبيره
نحن
المعركه في البلاد هي معركه بين
الديمقراطيه وبينها الديكتاتوريه التي
تريد ان تصادر مكاسب ثورتنا المباركه
الملفات المرفوعه ضدنا هي ملفات فارغه
بشهاده كل رجال القانون نحن هذه ليست
مشكلات البلاد ليست مشكله بلاد الغنوشي او
الطبوبيه او الشاب بمشكل تونس
هو هذا الانقلاب الغاسم الذي يدفع البلاد
دفعا نحو مزيد من المصائب او المجعاعات
والعياذ بالله
اعتقالنا واعتقاء واعتقال عدد من
المناضلين من اتجاهات مختلفه لن يحل
مشكلات الغلاء والعلم معيشه في تونس
الغلاسه التاسع